more chaos and unrest in major American
cities in Washington DC the American
flag going up in flames and protesters
threatening to tear down the Lincoln
emancipation memorial the National Guard
not being called in to protect statues
in the nation's capital men with long
guns gathered in Atlanta outside the
Wendy's where Rashard Brooks was killed
with some same cops are not allowed and
over in Wisconsin things took a violent
turn at the State Capitol
crowds toppling to statues including one
of a colonel who fought on the Union
side in the Civil War a democratic state
the Democratic state senator also
attacked President Trump promising to
stop the vandalism with an executive
order take a look I think many of the
people that are knocking down these
statues don't even have any idea what
the statue is what it means who it is
they're looking at George Washington
they're looking at Abraham Lincoln
Thomas Jefferson not gonna happen not
gonna happen not as long as I'm here as
far as Democrats are concerned I think
they could care less whether or not it
happens and I think the American people
get it so we're gonna have a very strong
executive order and it'll happen very
quickly before the end of the week Jesse
the National Guard that's been called in
in Washington DC they'll be there they
will be unarmed I'm not so sure that's
the best idea given that some of these
have turned quite violent as the States
Senator in Wisconsin found out but at
some point in addition to an executive
order you have to have some order and
how are we going to get that as this
continues every single night well the
mayors have to step up but they won't so
the feds have to back them up that
Democrats really aligned themselves with
a great movement heck of a job guys
start off ok and then you have a bunch
of looters arsonists homicidal maniacs
people that want to tear down Lincoln I
mean for a second maybe I guess the
Republicans were on their heels not
anymore
I mean you run against this and the fall
it's a layup kneeling for the anthem
taking down Jefferson burning things
assaulting gay progressive politicians
in swing states no no no no no the
Democrats had a moment of unity and they
destroyed it if you listen to Tim Scott
today on the Senate floor he said listen
the Democrats had 80% of what they
wanted in this police reform bill and
instead of taking that and then trying
to win in November and then finishing up
the last 20% they toss it all out
because they just want to campaign on
the issue they don't want to solve the
issue so now they have 0% anything the
Democrats take power they're gonna pass
police reform now they're not even going
to try this was a part of time when you
had everybody almost in agreement and
they threw it away if the Democrats had
backed a movement that was nonviolent
they had done civil disobedience maybe
that wouldn't persuaded some people but
I know a lot of people right now they're
looking around they're not talking to
pollsters and not posting on social
media they're not gonna say it do you
think they're voting for Joe Biden after
they see what's going on they're
absolutely not voting for Joe Biden when
they see this and if you look at the
people tearing down the statues and
assaulting police officers and burning
things do they even look like people
that vote they don't look like the most
civic minded responsible people if you
know what I mean so I'd be careful if I
tried to ride this wave to November so I
want to I do want to ask about the
police reform bill because one there was
this about for two weeks bipartisan
agreement police reform is needed and
necessary the house put forward a bill
the Senate put forward a bill senator
Tim Scott took direct language from
Kamala Harris's bill Cory Booker's bill
Gary Peters bill put it all into his and
still they declined to allow it to go to
a vote but then you had House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi say this about the
Republicans what something can happen
they're going to have to say
realities of police brutality the rav
lead of the need for justice and
policing and the recognition that there
are many many good people and law
enforcement but not all but so far they
were trying to get away with murder
actually the murder of jewelers boys how
how can anyone with a good conscience
you know say that but also if you're the
Speaker of the House aren't you supposed
to just want to try to get legislation
passed yeah I think she does want to try
to get legislation passed he just
doesn't want weak legislation that
really would not take advantage of this
moment where so many people are outraged
by what happened with George Floyd I'm
an augury you saw today some police
officers were charged in that case so I
I just I mean to me there's a yes but
they weren't they were on they were not
on duty officers but what about the fact
that Nancy Pelosi said no that the
Republicans who universally agreed that
what happened to George Floyd was a
murder was outrageous and they wanted to
do police reform and she says that
because it so she said thinks it's a
weak bill that the murder of George
Floyd is now on the Republicans no she's
saying that they are trying to move away
from the power of this moment with a
weak bill Dana and I think that she has
a very good point
that didn't even ban this choke business
so to me you want something that has
significance that speaks to the power of
the moment to me like you know when you
pick out cherry pick some of these
instances of violence and violence is
always bad you have to keep in mind that
it's not representative of the power of
this moment I mean it reminds me you
know of people here in Washington DC
senators who said they did not want that
to have a march on Washington 63 they
fared they beat violence or George
Wallace who said I don't want a monitor
across the Pettis bridge because it'll
tie up traffic those people are missing
the power of this moment which is black
and white Americans coming together to
address racism in this country all right
but is it eclipsing the moment when you
have situations like this Gregg take a
look at what happened to Andrea Mitchell
at in be over at MSNBC and Eleanor
Holmes Norton in Washington yesterday
[Music]
where do you think Greg I love the hair
I have to say Dana I didn't know you
were so fast
look Andrea Mitchell shows two sides of
the media right the fake in the real and
so the fake side is there's an epidemic
of police violence that's the fake the
real help I need the police so you it is
a perfect comparison the fake is up
liberals are the party of compassion the
real they're destroying our country
inside out it's private property public
property people they're feeding up but
we have this false belief the fake this
is Trump's America no this is what
happens when you let the insane take
over the asylum what kills me is that
the the left no doubt commits an
overwhelming bulk of violence yet their
ideology gets a total pass historically
and even today by the media academia
entertainment no one's talking about
this stuff they're too busy pointing at
the Trump rally at those thugs who
basically just wave flags where these
people burn flags and I'm sorry I'm so
I'm kind of over this like but you know
protesting is such an important part of
America we aren't we get that you need a
new line because this isn't protesting
every day that you apologize for this
stuff Juan you let the country suffer
and Democrats you've got to understand
liberals you have to understand this
isn't the same left that you are used to
this is a different kind of left wing
the left before actually allowed for
dialogue conversation to debate the
modern left now they're not interested
in to open your mind opening your mind
unless it's with a crowbar and you're
being false to your party and Falls to
the people that are your friends by
denying that this isn't a bad scene a
destructive scene and something that's
going to destroy this country you got to
stop apologizing for this crap that's
not what I'm saying at all but I but I
know we need to move on but just let me
just say that's not what I'm saying it's
a total distortion of what I'm trying to
say here all right I do want to get
digging in
because diggin that all of this is
happening while the country is trying to
reopen while you still have millions of
tens of millions of people unemployed
well food bank lines or overwhelmed and
we are not focusing on trying to deal
with that problem because if you are
have violence that is what is going to
be the headline of the day violence made
worse by effect less governors and
particularly mayors of left-wing cities
I call it the left-wing Luna verse Nancy
Pelosi and her ilk in Washington are
trying to blame President Trump for all
of this and give cover and make excuses
for all these people running these
cities who are showing willful blindness
to murder and mayhem in lower-income
neighborhoods and minority neighborhoods
they govern like they have a deep
abiding hatred of the people in their
cities it is disgusting and it's going
to give rise to vigilante justice people
taking up arms illegally and organized
crime because you know what small shop
owners and individual citizens they
don't have writ they're not rich they
don't have security with them like
Andrea Mitchell they have to fend for
themselves and they're going to wind up
paying gangsters to protect them because
governors and mayor's won't and don't
all right good talk everybody